from a live-action Disney adaptation to
some of the biggest sci-fi films of the
year March is stacked with movies well
worth checking out at the box office
update your calendar fill your pockets
with snacks shovel your car out of the
snow and check out this onslaught of
March movies Logan director James
Mangold's Logan could really be Hugh
Jackman's last hurrah
as Wolverine the film is a loose
adaptation of Marvel's old man Logan
comics arc and will dive into the darker
side of the x-men universes possible
future the film also features fan
favorite Wolverine clone x-23 big screen
debut the story finds an aged Wolverine
with a failing healing factor and broken
spirits protecting an older Professor X
at the end of his life the early
trailers look fantastic and Jackman even
took a pay cut to ensure the filmmakers
would have the flexibility to create the
r-rated story properly get ready for the
end on March 3rd before I fall think of
it like Groundhog Day but a lot weaker
and for the teen girl set this sci-fi
light drama is based on the 2010 novel
of the same name by Lauren Oliver and
follows a 17 year old girl who has to
relive the day of her death over and
over until she figures out how to get it
right
young Sam played by Zoe Deutsch uses her
time loop to try and avoid her fate and
eventually finds the freedom to take
chances and learns there's a lot more to
life than she thought check it out on
March 3rd and then check it out again
and again and again heetu Trainspotting
- it's been more than 20 years but
director Danny Boyle is back with a
long-awaited sequel through his pulpit
black comedy crime drama complete with
original stars Ewan McGregor
Ewen Bremner Jonny Lee Miller and Robert
Carlyle expectations are high for Boyle
to follow up his modern classic but by
loosely basing the story on the original
novel sequel porno he at least has a
template to follow reviews have been
largely positive in the UK where t2 is
already in theaters spot it in the US on
March 3rd Kong Skull Island Hollywood's
most famous angry Apes aside from Gary
Busey returns to the big screen
on March 10th alongside a listers tom
hiddleston samuel l.jackson
john goodman john c reilly and brie
larson the plot seems fairly predictable
but still relentlessly fun a team of
explorers and soldiers venture onto an
uncharted island in the Pacific which
just happens to include a whole lot of
monsters I call skull cross why never
said that name out loud before it sounds
stupid now that I say just you call them
whatever you want legendary is
reportedly looking to combine the world
of Kong and Godzilla for the first time
since their first showdown in 1962 so
this one should also help set the stage
for even more monster insanity you just
know they're going to bring the big guy
back to New York right the Valco
experiment this high concept horror film
was written by guardians of the galaxy
james gunn and follows a group of 80
white-collar office workers trapped in a
violent social experiment in which the
workday suddenly becomes a life-or-death
game it's basically Glengarry Glen Ross
meets battle royale meets soft and
features a long list of familiar faces
getting shattered with the blood of
their co-workers so if you ever wanted
to actually see John McKinley from
office space going ham in an office get
your TPS reports in by March 17th Beauty
and the Beast if you're a living
breathing human being you already know
the story of Beauty and the Beast so
you're probably not in for any huge
surprises Disney has realized that
turning its Animated Classics until
live-action blockbusters is pretty big
business and this marks the latest
installment of more than 20 planned
adaptation like usual for Mouse House
has assembled an all-star cast including
Emma Watson Dan Stevens Luke Evans and a
whole lot of computers to make that
talking clock believable your furry
fantasies come to life on March 17th
free fire this action comedy from high
rise director Ben Wheatley starred brie
Larson sharlto copley army hammer
Cillian Murphy and Jack Rayner as a
bunch of criminals who get stuck in an
arm deal Don terribly wrong a
disagreement turns into a shootout
violent comedy ensues and in early buzz
is to be believed
it's full of punchy laughs and a high
injury counts
desire is set to launch in the u.s. on
March 17th King Arthur legend of the
sword Guy Ritchie is taking a break from
his Sherlock Holmes franchise to put a
fresh spin on the classic story of King
Arthur due out March 24th the story
follows a young Arthur who learns about
his royal lineage after pulling
Excalibur from a stone with great sword
comes great responsibility and Arthur
has to make some tough decisions happy
to talk but there is no way I am
fighting despite its obvious period
setting the film looks like a more
modern action filled take on the classic
story filled with a-list talent Power
Rangers for adults of a certain age the
reimagining of the Power Rangers
franchise has been a long time coming
the 90s kid series is getting a
big-screen reboot as a pg-13 action
franchise so if you've ever wanted to
see Bryan Cranston as a giant
disembodied head your dream come true on
March 24th director Dean Israelite has
put together a nice mix of stars
including Elizabeth Banks and a team of
young up and comers to play the teenage
Rangers Israelites previous film project
Almanac did a good job with its teen
protagonists so this one has the
potential to be a whole lot of fun one
thing's for sure is bulk and skull don't
make a cameo we riot life this side by
horror thriller follows a team of
astronauts who retrieve a Mars space
probe with a sample inside because
nothing good ever comes from Mars all
hell breaks loose and the crew has to
find a way to stop the space monster
while trapped onboard the International
Space Station if it sounds like alien
well that's because it pretty much is
alien with a twist
the cast of doomed spaceman includes
Jake Gyllenhaal Rebecca Ferguson Ryan
Reynolds and Hiroyuki Sanada get probed
on March 24th ships this buddy cop
comedy stars writer director Dax Shepard
and Michael Pena as two California
Highway Patrol motorcycle officers who
investigate a corrupt police department
by making at least one Weiner joke every
three minutes
sure chips is a comedy centric remake of
the 1970s Evie drama but that worked out
pretty well for 21 Jump Street
I never do a chef famous remember how
much you liked the Starsky and Hutch and
Dukes of Hazzard movies well even if you
didn't there's still a lot of talent and
potential here Ryder died on March 24th
ghosts in the shelves the long-awaited
live-action adaptation of this acclaimed
manga and anime looks like one of the
most ambitious sci-fi films of the year
Scarlett Johansson no stranger to
skin-tight action stars as a cyborg
major as she and her counter cyber
terrorist unit take on cyber saboteurs
the film looks to be a gorgeous
translation of the visuals from the
anime so no matter how it turns out
there seems to be no doubt director
Rupert Sanders has built something
gorgeous ghost in the shell' gets
uploaded to theaters on March 31st
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]